sunday's game should be amazing it's the
greatest of all time tom brady versus
the young gun
patrick mahomes yeah yeah but for
everybody else it's all
about the commercials that's a good
point
and because we are e.t we were on set
for some of the most
epic super bowl ads of all time
[Music]
they have genius commercials so we have
to make sure our commercial is really
cool
eating gangnam style
oh yeah a lot of people don't see me
from pop stars to sports stars hey et
welcome to the set of my first super
bowl commercial to reality stars and
their momagers
mom we're filming we've been with
every celeb who knows the value of
having the world's biggest audience
watching it's a marvelous opportunity
for me it's it's kind of up there it's
pretty iconic to do a super bowl
commercial
but maybe the most iconic cindy crawford
who told us
she initially wasn't aware she was going
to serve up
so much sex appeal in this 1992 pepsi ad
these are the jeans that i was wearing
to the commercial and they were like
do you mind if we cut your jeans i'm
like no so these are them
and cindy's not the only one who learned
sexy cells
i am so excited this is my first
commercial
after breaking up a muppet fight in 2004
jessica was back in 06
and got a reported 1 million bucks to
return again in 2007.
i think that i'm gonna go have myself
some more cheesy bites to be honest with
you
cheesy bites i thought i was the pop
star huh
you wish my favorite muppet is
definitely miss piggy yes sometimes we
caught celebs collaborating with their
favorites sometimes
not marker and action
yo terry what is it al never heard of
this guy
i don't want to hurt his feelings you
feel stupid
you're talking to a puppet gentlemen i
really enjoyed your work in germany
we were with a six-year-old sporty
jonathan lipnicki
right after jerry maguire teaming up for
a nike ad with a 21 year old tiger woods
my goal is my aspiration i'm gonna try
to live up to those through the tunnel
over the cheerleaders off let's see his
head
we were also with basketball legends
michael jordan and larry bird
for several memorable mcdonald's ads
including this one
with charles barkley hey can i play no
charles wants to be a part of it i'm
just trying to get in the game
oh i can't wait to retire dude
at age 88 betty white was ready to
tackle this hilarious ad for snickers
never even knowing what a hit it would
become you're playing like betty white
out there that's not what your
girlfriend said
baby i didn't know it was going to air
on the super bowl
and it was a delightful surprise
millions of gigs of unused data are
taken back by wireless companies
tragic kim kay was well aware getting
paid to mock her own
self-promoting ways i'm kind of poking
fun at the idea
of the ridiculousness of everyone and
their selfies i love it
i'm a big fan of selfies data you paid
for that can be used to see
my makeup my backhand my outfits
good evening we interrupt your regularly
scheduled broadcast for this super
important message but the best or worst
part
super bowl ads live on forever i'm in my
underwear
right your children will grow up and
watch this i mean it could be worse they
could grow up and have to watch
something else so
you